[Music]
in can't please everyone news man
submitted by CatDog i remember the new
dora the explorer' movie trailer drops
and fans have a lot to say resident
mexican here i didn't like it because
she wasn't a child I don't want her to
be a cute kid it kind of dropped out of
nowhere like people had kind of heard
maybe it was gonna be a movie like a
live-action is yeah she better speak
some [ __ ] Spanish a live-action is
[ __ ] live-action movies with a few
cartoons she's too old I'm going to play
it for you ok ok I don't know anything
about Dora the Explorer no play it for
you it was we were in kids anymore oh
yeah it was a preschool show only no cuz
my nephews and nieces Danny drink tray
holes in it oh he's in all the I think
what they did is they try to grow her
with the audience that's true it seems
like a fun movie but I don't know
anything about those people that people
that watched her like so if I think
about my nieces and nephews that grew up
watching they're all like in high school
now oh so they probably who's not gonna
watch they're in high school then the
kids watching are gonna be maybe junior
high high school yeah yeah yeah cuz the
youngest one yeah she's in junior high
so yeah cuz I don't know anything about
Dori either but I just remember she was
like a girl like this a little toddler
remember that mean that was going around
where there was a Mexican girl that took
a picture and they're like oh my god
it's Dora the Explorer I see that's what
I picked your Dora to look like yeah so
they like say it's gonna be set ten
years later
yes that's why Diego looks like so
different yeah and there was like a lot
of mixed reviews so first there you have
the camp of people that are like that's
nothing like Dora the Explorer okay if
you're gonna do it Dora the Explorer
movie the monkey has name is boots he
doesn't have boots in the movie that's
his whole thing is that he's a monkey
and boots and he doesn't have boots in
the movie the second thing was that like
if you're gonna make it a live-action
why not make it like the cartoon have
like a CGI arrow have like a talking
backpack which was one of the main
things in the movie in the show like a
lot of the things that made the show
what it was are not featured in the
movie it is like this is Tomb Raider
like the beginning yeah that's what I
was thinking it's like a Tomb Raider
Indiana Jones but this is not Dora the
Explorer it is an adaptation yeah it's a
teenage Dora the Explorer I like so if
door grew up that that argument kind of
works if they're literally doing Dora
the Explorer but they're doing an
adaptation of it so that's just like you
know what it is and how to be a hardcore
fan of Dora the Explorer as an adult why
are you so mad there's like watching the
way the Pooh movie and then I [ __ ]
see like like Pooh is not a bright
yellow and I'm like who was bright
yellow what the [ __ ] you know yeah but
then you have another camp people that
are like damn it actually looks like
it's gonna be a good movie also it's
like one of the first like mainstream
movies that has a full Latino yeah cast
Danny Trejo Xena Michael Pena Benicio
del Toro Benicio del Toro voice of Doras
nemesis Swiper Isabel she teaches
Spanish while she's doing this all right
Ava Longoria is in it I think she speaks
Spanish in the show doesn't she
sometimes she tour Noah Dora what's your
roots man stop the screen and say hey
puta this [ __ ] is a puta well and they
say that it's kind of like edgy comedy -
because it's also directed by the same
guy that did flight of the conchords and
the Muppets movie and so they're saying
it could
be kind of like edgy comedy no no their
most recent one the one that came out a
few years ago you guys noticed that
section where the guy was like come with
me if you want to live I was like you
aim the [ __ ] Arnold bro I don't know
if that's an auteur
is terrible for nod you know what I
would like to see come with me action
movie of Barney would like a real
dinosaur yeah and it's like a scary
dinosaur Jurassic Park but a Barney yeah
yeah when he appears is not even like
sparkles it's a portal and you just see
[ __ ] hell on the other side it's a
horror movie that's the way he was
singing this song with Warren it's like
at the end with the music box
when bebop comes out is a guy that
smoking culturally inappropriate cuz
he's imitating like hip-hop culture from
people and in be Bob gets kidnapped by
the Crips and stuff Oh Martin he has to
come in like rescue them Oh gonna be so
tight did you guys watch Barney no it
was a little bit younger yeah same
that's I only know of Barney yeah cuz
like the little kids of church I was
Sesame Street Reading Rainbow Muppet
Babies LeVar Burton said I was funny
don't he was at my apartment in Cape
Town doing a photo shoot there that's
tight he said you're funny and I was
like you know what that's pretty funny
physical call only guy in real life that
like tripped on a [ __ ] banana peel
they recorded me slipping on ice cubes
oh so oh sorry old cartoon that [ __ ] was
dope hold a live action with John
Leguizamo
the movie at the movie movie was three
people are tuned tomorrow really I'd
like that hey glee remember hey guys too
young for that I remember the one with
Don Lobos amo yeah there was an into a
Sonic the Hedgehog card hey ya Sonic the
Hedgehog I remember for sure yeah do you
remember the live-action Mario show no
had like Martin two Italian guys
it's like getting like cartoony ass like
toilet you stupid son-of-a-bitch they
would teach you different things about I
was like really young but they called it
Mario what a [ __ ] hilarious
and stupid concept as a Japanese built
game about two Italian [ __ ]
walking dinosaurs shooting fireballs out
there's somebody [ __ ] pissed that to
me I'd be like get the [ __ ] out of here
you psychopath Japanese has the best
racists games ever like Street Fighter
that is the most racist game you could
think of it's awesome yeah Indian guy
eats curry at the end and he stretches
the bill in Russian they just do it like
they see it like they're like on their
kids they like it's like he's from the
Air Force guy he has this flattop and
like yeah it's so funny because the
Italian Mario even has like a really bad
Italian accent it's like from Japan
Italian accent please would you take
taiko to see Dora
yeah would it mine it's a button kids a
fun kid movie like it's so hard for me
not you like to be against kid movies
cuz they're fun like kid knew the
positive is fun yeah and they're super
positive of course I would take them and
I like all these actors yeah I would
take them Tigers gotta be like three or
four those do down right now because
like what if they [ __ ] up a piece of
your childhood they didn't do it right
true how many they do that all the time
actions of all the old Disney cartoons
and they never turn out good I mean
hopefully a lot it turns out but like
Beauty and the Beast did not go I love
Will Smith but I'm not looking forward
to seeing you know my childhood which
was Robin Williams
I mean like I love Will Smith like I
love him but I I don't watch what are
people like boycott this [ __ ] no people
are just like really pissed off that the
monkey doesn't have boots or like why
does the birds have boots in there
because you wouldn't be able to grab
things because it's prehensile he needs
his [ __ ] hand if the monkey had boots
they're just there'd be just as many
people outraged and they put a monkey
with boots on it's not a real monkey
it's a CGI monkey both still get paid
and then they're like if you're gonna
CGI the monkey why not CGI the backpack
talking you know why not CGI all day I
said nobody gives a [ __ ] you losers
you're a dog it's for children shut the
[ __ ] up the thing is it looks like
they're trying to make this more
realistic too yeah it would be like if
they did a Snow White and there was only
two Dwarfs and you're like why not the
Seven Dwarves like white magic grumpy is
because I saw a porno and they had all
seven and I'm like that's it's a good
parody
hey that's a really good seven of them
they were there in that poo tango but
they had like your crown and then one of
them like has sex with her and then
everyone in the background are like no
they're just kind of like you missed
opportunities but we she would suck the
German or something yeah it's a parody
it's a whole movie it's like a gangbang
or is the Alice in Wonderland one which
was yeah I'm Joe yep I remember that
there's there's what you call it the the
the [ __ ] scarecrows not the Wizard of
Oz the Wizard of Oz one
like that one as much as no way no way
they got a castle and everything dude I
was surprised it's old you know how
there's historic like nineteen porn
historians yeah 1952 I want to hear your
guys's [ __ ] riding circle you're all
referencing like Shawshank Redemption
and then he pulls in [ __ ] the porn
shows you watch Harry Potter and the
Sorcerer's bone it's terrible
[Music]